je sais que des milliers de questions
doivent se bousculer dans votre tête
est-ce que c'est l'endroit qu'il me faut
est-ce que je suis à ma place
laissez-moi vous assurer que nous voyons
quelque chose en vous quelque chose que
vous ne voyez peut-être pas vous-même
même si vous avez une vision à rayon X
félicitations et bienvenue à la
godalking University
golden boy s'enflamme il se retrouve à
poil
c'est comme un gigantesque concombre
ils ont tout réussi ils vont sauver des
vies par milliers je t'ai trouvé un an
de super héros qui veulent entendre
[Musique]
retournera jamais dans cette de
forêt
il se passe des trucs très bizarre ici
je t'interdis de parler de ça
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il y a des gens vraiment maléfiques dans
cette école c'est énorme ça ne dépasse
tous faut qu'on fasse quelque chose
c'est ta chance d'avoir un vrai pouvoir
va pas tenter de faire des exploits de
minéraux
rechercher la vérité c'est exactement
c'est un peu parti en couille là non
répondez pas c'est une question
rhétorique
c'est qu'une question de temps avant
qu'il découvre tout ce qu'on fait
d'autre ici
il y a des fuites sur la forêt on va au
devant d'un problème potentiellement
fatale
c'est complètement taré je suis
complètement taré
la seule chose qui saute clairement aux
yeux c'est qu'on est tous complètement
taré
[Musique]